I see you have another guest.
Oh, no.
Milady!
Lady Tsuyuko!
I found this bug at the Shinsen Temple!
Thank you, Kerao.
A little praying mantis.
There's something different about it.
Lady Tsuyuko, have a look at mine!
The snail has an inverted shell.
Excellent work, Amahiko.
And Inagomaro?
That insect that you found by the river?
I named it Splishy-Splash!
Splishy-Splash?
Oh? And who might you be?
He's already this big?
Isn't he a marvel?
I can't wait to see what he'll grow into.
He will become evil.
After all, he's a sekisanko.
A sekisanko?
An insect spirit born from kodoku magic.
Once out of its cocoon,
it uses lethal curses to kill.
Kill who?
Whoever you hate
because you're the one who raised it.
But I don't hate anyone.
Deep inside every human,
there exists a dark soul.
A sekisanko is a vicious spirit
that can sense your darkest secrets.
Let me exorcise him before he pupates.
Wait!
Don't be so quick to judge!
Kuromaru is precious to me.
I know it's hard for you to understand.
You're an ignorant fool, incapable
of understanding the human heart!
Then allow me to be there when he emerges.
If I see that he's evil,
I'll exorcise him.
Will you agree to that?
Thank you, Lord Seimei.
Please do so.